[Music]
dawn of the Planet of the Apes is
directed by Matt Reeves this is the
sequel to the surprisingly good rise as
a Planet of the Apes which came out a
few years back but my movie came out a
lot of people were not really that into
that film they were like Planet of the
Apes
how much farther are we gonna go to this
reboot thing a lot farther trust me that
was 2011 we went really far with the
reboot sequel thing but it was actually
a very good movie and a very enticing
movie because it hinted at greatness
dawn of the Planet of the Apes picks up
a few years later in fact quite a bit of
years later where mankind is very
dwindling in this film they're trying to
get access to this dam that is nearby so
they can try to reroute some power back
to where they are unfortunately between
them and that dam is Caesar and his
group of apes and so a power struggle
starts between the Apes and the humans
and they have to try to figure out a way
to be able to get to that dam to restore
power there's also a bit of a power
struggle going on amongst the Apes
themselves and I was very excited for
this movie and not just because I
enjoyed the predecessor I think Matt
Reeves is a terrific director and did he
deliver yes he did this guy can direct a
movie this movie the looks fan tastic
from the opening shot of this movie I
was mesmerised the scenes in this film
are so incredibly powerful there is such
a great undercurrent of emotion flowing
through this movie the Apes are so well
realized through the motion capture work
I mean there are times we were just
looking in the fur and the sweats and
everything it just looks so incredible
an anti circus I mean has Andy Serkis
ever done a motion capture performance
that wasn't absolutely balls-out awesome
I don't want to oversell it
but at some point give this man an Oscar
his performance as Caesar is
heartbreaking empowering enthralling and
a whole bunch of other descriptive words
to say that he does an incredible job in
this movie he really really is the heart
and soul of this movie Jason Clark plays
our main human protagonist in the film
and my best compliment that I can give
him is that he just feels so natural he
doesn't feel like an actor who is acting
he just feels so real in his scenes and
he did a very good job in this movie
Gary Oldman also in this film who plays
a man who is very much so on the edge of
hating these Apes that's one of the
largest things that's explored in this
movie is the hatred of something that's
unfamiliar the hatred of another race or
another group of people because within
the group of Apes themselves there's a
few Apes where you're like something
isn't entirely right there and you can
see a power struggle going on and it's
the same thing with the humans as well
because there's a lot of prejudice
towards these Apes because a lot of
people looking at them as the thing that
wipes out humankind through the simian
flu so not only is this a remarkable
technological achievement the special
effects the music the way the film is
directed all of that motion capture work
looks and sounds absolutely terrific
there's such a great emotional core to
this movie where you can really get
attached to the Apes I won't lie I cried
in this movie I cried it's very rare for
me I don't usually tear up but in this
movie it just hit me a certain scene
that I won't get into it just boomed
there it was this movie is emotionally
powerful and at the same time it's
enthralling as an action film Matt
Reeves does an excellent job directing
the action in this film every shot feels
as if it is necessary there's a lot of
really powerful imagery in this movie to
where you're watching and you're
thinking yourself this ape action movie
is actually saying a lot of really
important shit Donna the Planet of the
Apes is a film that improves in every
way on its predecessor everything about
this movie is better than the last one
it is the Dark Knight - Batman Begins it
is the Empire Strikes Back to Star Wars
my only issue with the film involves
some dialogue in the script sometimes a
dialogue really does come off as
exposition certain characters are
introduced me of quickly are told
exactly what that person is and why
they're there and what they're doing and
it doesn't exactly feel like something
that a person would say in real life it
feels as if characters are saying it to
the audience there are times when
characters will walk into a scene and
say well it's been two days so what's
going on and you're like okay it's been
two days like it's just really
expositional dialogue that is my only
gripe with
this movie and I am nitpicking at this
point Donna the Planet of the Apes is an
absolutely terrific film do not miss
this movie it's better than the first
I'm giving it an A it is one of the best
films I've seen so far this year Andy
Serkis deserves at least an Oscar
nomination for this movie and I know
people have been saying that all the way
back since Gollum but Academy listen to
me listen remember when that guy in the
Academy last year got that movie
nominated for Best Song and everyone was
like what was that movie and it was
eventually research and discovered that
he was just some high up guy he used to
be in the Academy a pretty high up name
that actually emailed a whole bunch of
people and convinced them to vote for it
yeah they've removed the nomination and
that guy got in trouble and everything
but it still got nominated didn't it
that's kind of frightening listen to
yourselves what the hell are you doing
nominate a nice circus this guy deserves
a Best Actor nomination he is absolutely
amazing in this movie given the
nomination he deserves it I'm serious
I'm gonna come find you if you don't
guys when you see this movie let me know
what you thought of it I really strongly
suggest checking this one out it is an
epic film that should not be missed in
theaters as always guys thank you so
much for watching and if you like this
you can click right here and get steppen
heist
[Music]